[Music]
[Applause]
j-lo's showstopper today with ben gave
us major 2003 oscars vibes laughing
leaning in sharing a private convo and
then a kiss benefit sure looked wedding
ready j.lo of vision in white with a
plunging neckline holding hands with her
dapper man in a tux she pulled off a
glam transformation changing into this
stunner six hours after
their this arrival j-lo beaming on a
boat and walking hand-in-hand with
affleck in pinstripes this is benifer's
first red carpet in 18 years remember
the geely premiere this movie will
always be important in a landmark event
in my life it's funny to look at it now
the venice film festival frenzy is all
for the last duel ben's new medieval
drama out next month with bestie matt
damon and jody comer what was it like
working with matt damon and ben affleck
on the last door they're both wonderful
very fun very darn to wear
i understood that you had to make an
outline
that was something of a shock to matt
both buds joked about riding together
again 24 years after goodwill hunting
but i was afraid with this album you'd
be having this millstone around my neck
a source tells e.t matt is very happy to
see ben in such a great place in his
life and in his relationship just don't
expect him to tag along on their
vacations i don't think i'd be invited
on that one i might be a bit of a third
wheel
as for benefer we're told the rekindled
couple now has a good grip on the media
attention and while things are getting
more and more serious jyn and ben are
taking it one day at a time but both are
happier than they have been in a very
long time